I am so happy to welcome you all to the
supper suite at South by Southwest 2019
huge thanks to El Tesoro for letting us
do these interviews today because that
means we could talk about movies like
book smart and I'm very excited about
this for a number of reasons that I'll
get to throughout the interview but
Katie I wanted to start with you here
because I'm also a huge fan of set it up
so it was wondering when did this script
pop up compared to that and has like the
past year to just been a major whirlwind
for you yes it was it's been really
really fun we started working on this
script right when set it up had finished
shooting so the fall of 2017 Wow yeah
September 20th 2017 and so it was fun
and you know that was another experience
there was a female director a female
producer like a very heavily female crew
and so it was that was a really great
experience in terms of knowing what
those benefits are and when I was
looking for a next project and something
came in that was at Annapurna and Gloria
Sanchez and Caitlin Deaver was attaching
the director was Olivia Wilde it was
like a dream email to respond to and so
it was just after that that I got to
kind of bound into this and you stepped
in for the rewrite phase so can you tell
me a little bit about what you infused
into the script that might not have been
there before yeah well Olivia brought so
many ideas she knew so much what it was
it's really fun to come onto a project
with such a clear specific vision and
even her pitch for the movie I wanted to
see before we knew how we were gonna
write it so that there was a very very
clear line and leader throughout the
whole process especially vibe wise and
so that was really really fun but it was
we were able to make it
I think autobiographical in that we
wanted to see the women that we knew and
the friendships that we had reflected
on-screen and in that way they're really
funny we were really excited to make a
comedy where the women got to be
multi-dimensional cuz I think in a lot
of comedies the female characters are
doing a very specific thing and so that
I was the jumping-off point in terms of
being able to see the women we know in
real life on screen in a fun way I think
one thing that's so extraordinary about
what Katie can do as a writer is she can
identify the different voices of the
character it's not like oh this is the
sort of tone of the comedy of the film
and everyone's gonna tell jokes within
that
same tone we were very specific about
each character and how they were really
funny in different ways and she's so
good at kind of stepping into all of
those roles and making them sharply
funny in different ways the
extraordinary process of finding your
own take on a film is so interesting and
you know I fell in love with the concept
of this film I had my take on it but the
experience of meeting Katie and had an
expressing my desire for what I thought
it could be and having her somehow put
that into words was really incredible
it's like a puzzle piece snapping into
place and it creates this exciting kind
of brain trust and I hope that everyone
can find a creative partner that can
help them communicate their ideas I
think a lot of people a lot of people
you know don't take that leap because
they don't find someone who can help
them kind of articulate some really some
ideas and I think you know there are
writers looking for directors and
directors looking for writers and really
the collaboration is magic I don't
really believe in the idea of like an
auteur who does everything on their own
it's like well that's fine if that's
what you want to do what I find fun
about this process is actually the team
sport collaboration and I think that
kind of is exactly how we approach this
together and it's how the cast
approached it so speaking from the
ensemble perspective I was wondering do
you guys take note that your director is
is also a very talented experienced
actor too can you feel the difference I
mean yeah you definitely can I feel like
it's it was really an incredible
experience
working with a director who has had a
lot of experience being an actor and
also she's just extremely talented but I
learned so much from her and I think
because that she was an actor before I
think you kind of learn what not to do
and how sets can be you can feel very
uncomfortable as an actor and Olivia
made the environment so open and fun and
made sure everyone felt good about what
they were doing and also she didn't put
anyone in a box she didn't make anyone
feel like okay
I'm in charge this is what I want it was
sort of just like let's talk about it
and let's collaborate it was really cool
I love hearing that
what is something one example of
something you do at the very beginning
to make sure everybody around you feels
kind of included and comfortable well I
mean first and foremost it's getting to
know each of the actors and what their
specific processes what's their
experience speak to them in the language
they speak you know you can't just say
this is the process this is how it's
gonna be because everyone comes to it's
a kind of a unique art form in that way
everyone comes with different training
different levels of experience someone
who's done a lot of theater training
speaks in a different language than
someone who's just all instinct and
doing this for the first time like a few
of our actors were and I really enjoyed
being able to empathize because if
there's one thing that acting gives us
is the ability to empathize so being
able to really connect with each actor
and think what's the best kind of
language to speak to you and what's
gonna help you get to where I know you
want to go and then just creating an
environment that was super conducive to
their success and in terms of you know
creating that vibe it was so much about
relaxation I think that that it's a
crazy thing to ask people to come
together on a film set which is so
chaotic it kind of feels like a
construction site that then at a certain
moment I don't have to be really quiet
and then the actor is expected to feel
things authentically and it's like
that's not gonna work you need to you
need to warm people up you got to get
people on the same rhythm we used a lot
of music to do that and a lot of just
conversations and I I really asked a lot
of them I asked everyone to be off-book
and that allowed the space to actually
have ideas on set no one was doing that
thing where they we've all seen it where
someone walks to set with their sides
going like oh this is that scene yeah I
said on the first day of prep I was like
if anyone is hiding set-asides
under them in a scene I'll flip out but
but no one did that everyone wanted to
bring so much professionalism to it so
to answer your question I just I created
the set I had always wanted and
everybody just so surpassed my
expectations and dreams immediately day
one I was like
gosh I mean we did the first day of
shooting was a really big scene it is
the the sort of scene that kicks off the
entire plot of the film it was a huge
amount of dialogue and and they were so
prepared and it was just a dream it was
we knew at that point that we were in
good hands with all these actors because
our viewers probably don't know too much
about the movie I was wondering if the
three of you could tell us a little
something about your characters and
maybe just because it sounds like this
isn't really this isn't really a movie
that sticks to any kind of stereotype so
what is one thing about your character
that you've never seen before in a movie
such a good question so I play Molly who
is an extremely focused passionate
dedicated human being academically and
then also to her best friend Amy she's
just she gives everything her all but
she sort of has rationalized that she
wants like she needs Amy and she needs
school and that's all she thought she
needed and then this huge bomb is
dropped on her by a character named
Triple A played by my best friend in
real life Molly Gordon which is really
exciting we play enemies in the film
which is very fun um and we don't want
to give too much away but huge bombs
dropped on this girl that my characters
projected a lot of assumptions onto she
thinks she's like this promiscuous dumb
girl and it turns out she's not that and
a rattles Molly's world and she goes to
Amy and she's like we have to show them
that we're smart and we're fun because
we are both of those things and we know
that so it's not necessarily this like
adventure movie it is all those things
but it's really just two girls trying to
prove that they are who they know they
are to the rest of their school and then
through that process they actually Molly
learns a lot about that she's the one
that's been doing a lot of judging no
one else has been doing as much judging
as she's been doing the whole time but
it's really about our friendship first
and foremost I play Amy and she is I
would say the same she excels in school
you know the type of girl who like
starts her own clubs and is smart in her
own way but really it's her whole life
it's been school and Molly and that's
kind of all she knows and then they go
on this amazing journey together and I
feel like the thing that attracted me
most about Amy and reading her and
bringing her to life is that she is a
girl that feels like me she's a girl
that feels like my friends my best
friends and the female friendship is so
strong in this movie that I don't think
I've ever seen really anything like it
I also feel like to answer the second
part of Russian is that usually if
there's that like bookish intense girl
she's alone
she doesn't have her person and everyone
has their person and so our movie is
showing that dynamic and I think what I
love about our film is that it shows 1 2
3 4 different people that could
generally be considered the same
archetype and so by doing that I just
bust that concept wide open because
we're both the smart girls you know
Billie and Skylar who plays Jared are
like the crazy rich party people but by
having more than one of those types it
just intrinsically just busts that
concept wide open and shows you that
none no one is a type and everyone is
and there's no shame in being smart or
just being 100% yourself and that you
like shouldn't judge a book by its cover
my character seems like she's this like
crazy party girls like kind of awful
person but then underneath it all you
find out that she has a bigger soul and
is more loyal than most of the other
people at her school so that's an
interesting thing that happens because
that happens in life all the time I was
talking about it earlier today when I
was in school I got voted most edgy and
most likely to be on the cover of a
tabloid Thank You harvard-westlake
students and that's not who I was like
yeah I went to Coachella and maybe I
went to a couple concerts but like I
loved school and worked my ass off and
was really into academics but people
thought I was this party girl but I was
not so Gigi keeping with that theme is
there anything personal about yourselves
that you wish that people knew Lee
especially being in this industry where
people see you on screen and I'm sure
judge all the time like what's something
that's really important to you that you
wish everyone out there kind of knew I
mean I I can speak for one thing that's
really exciting about releasing this
film is that the letting the world know
how many incredibly funny funny
actresses are working right now and all
of these girls have done funny movies
but I think they get to show their
comedy chops in this film it's such a
brilliant way and it's so exciting for
me when people see the film when they
leave and they're like oh my god they
all made me laugh so hard and and it's
still it's really important that we
continue to show that women are funny
and can be funny in different ways and I
I
that's something I'm excited to reveal
to the show like these are some of the
funniest girls I've ever met and I'm
really excited for everyone get to enjoy
that that's the thing I was gonna say
she put so much trust into everyone that
I think that every single person in this
movie you're never gonna see them at
this heightened experience I don't I
don't think that they they are they are
so specific and intricate and it's
because Olivia put like 100% of her
trust into all of us behind the camera
like she made everyone better at every
level of every part of this process and
that's what made it so special
your checks are in the mail you're doing
very well the shock collars later I was
also wondering about your experience
going from because we were talking about
it before one of the first times I
interviewed you it was for a documentary
short and I've never forgotten that film
those films actually and then also I was
wondering having worked with Reed is
there anything about her I that kind of
stuck with you because another shot that
I'll never get out of my head is the one
with the yellow hoodie walking through
Times Square I love the way you remember
things that's so great I can't believe
how much I remember I know I learned a
huge amount so speaking of like female
friendships Reed Morano is one of my
dear friends and is a huge inspiration
to me she's someone who was one of the
best cinematographers working one of the
only women's cinematographers and and
broke out of that role into directing
and I had the honor of producing her
directorial debut and watching her
not only direct that but also DP that
and operate was extraordinary because
she was so confident about her vision
and that really inspired me you have to
make the film only you can make it's not
worth it don't try to make something
everybody enjoys make something you
enjoy and there will be an audience for
it but you have to be specific and
confident in that and Reid is so good at
that she also takes real risks and she
you know the the hoodie shot she's
talking about was originally a 12-minute
Steadicam shot following me walking
through Times Square just on my back and
I think there's a lot of people I think
we cut it down to a couple minutes for
the final film but um also extraordinary
that a female DP and operator could
operate a camera and for that many
minutes by the way walking after me
because I walk very quickly through
Times Square but just the idea that you
know confidence in your choices as a
director saying I know it's on the back
of her head I'm gonna keep this camera
here and we're gonna take this risk you
know there are several shots in this
film that I'm really proud of we had an
extraordinary operator named Chris Hart
off who was so great I mean he had done
everything from casino to Birdman and
when I knew he did Birdman I was like
we're gonna do some long Steadicam shots
but I really feel that that having a
friend to look at and admire in their
kind of courage in their art form only
pushes you to have that courage and she
was pumping me up the whole way through
and and you know I was hopefully doing
that as much for her but it's another
example of female friendship and the
power of it and the value of it and that
those relationships often get sort of
like undervalued because we put so much
focus in this culture on romantic
relationships but you know that's that's
what's happening right now and the world
women are connecting there's been a
revolution in the last year and a half
two years now like there people are
waking up and realizing you're your
female peers are your support system and
we have to do this together it really
throws me how many times I've had that
conversation in just like the last two
months alone and I I thought I can
of it I am so excited to see this movie
thank you guys so much for coming in I
have so many more questions but thank
you for another time
thank you guys out there for watching
this interview book-smart Keith may 24th
right here from the supper suite at
South by Southwest
thanks a lot we've got more coverage
coming for you real soon